Christian Elder, Screenwriter: It's not
what he's playing, it's not the chord
that he's hitting, it's what's between.
It's the stop. It's in between it,
that is where you feel the
story he's telling in the music.
Film Courage: How did you figure out your voice?
Christian: I yelped into the wind and no… you know
when you asked me that question immediately the
first thing that popped into my mind and it really
has nothing to do with anything we're discussing
was the first few lines of James Joyce's
A Portrait of the Artist as a Young Man
and what that story and that book means
as a tale about this modernist tale
that is descriptive of how an artist reaches his
voice that is descriptive in the way that it tells
how that artist reaches his voice because anybody
familiar with Portrait of the Artist knows that
it starts with these kind of
weird little phonetics because
he's like he's just a he's just a baby and he
like he's like looking out on a pastor and he sees
cows and he's like moo cow and stuff like that
and it's and and then it slowly develops into
what becomes a language that starts to
become sophisticated which is the the
is considered like what people said was
brilliant about James Joyce and it is brilliant
um also they said that James Joyce apparently
he was very very influenced it was like he was
the very first generation of of of novelists
that were influenced by cinema had influence on
writing the novel as opposed to and
that was early cinema very early sooner
yeah because I just got lost in thinking about
portrait of the artist it's such a good book
we'll put a link down to it below you know it's
okay so how I figured it out I talked a little bit
about that before and that that really was kind of
discovering how to write in these terse sentences
I already had a a a a sense of how to write decent
dialogue and I was just honing that along with
creating these little terse bursts of of
description to create the scene structure
that was working for me simultaneously
I learned how to outline now outlining
for me at that time was something I used a
structure of 12 beats I think it's a I think
in the beginning the way I worked it out and also
the way I was taught because there was various
areas that I picked up some of the the skill set
that I had I’d read of course the art of dramatic
screenwriting I mean dramatic
writing I also was very fond of
of some of David Mamet's essays and books I
took a couple courses here and there and so
I distilled it down to writing a premise or a
log line for the for the the overall um idea of
what the story would be and that that premise or
log line has the is is elastic in itself meaning
that it it can evolve it can change over time you
can always return to it and augment it in some way
as you are going through the writing process and
then for each of the 12 beats of my screenplay
so basically when I say 12 beats is if
a screenplay is technically 120 pages
there's a beat for every 10 pages
all right and then you're thinking of
of the story and we're talking the story now
as an ekg all right so what I mean by an ekg
and you can also apply this to Christopher
Vogler's ideas on The Hero's Journey as well
the ekg is like you are you are lifting off with
your inciting incident the inciting incident
technically should occur anywhere from like the
five page to to like well in the old days it was a
five page defer to 30 page but like it's it's
really just five pages now you really don't go
farther than that and then and then what you do
is you you plateau off as you get towards the
towards the middle of the ekg so that's like
page 60 and that means basically that your
characters or your protagonist is on his way
to towards his journey and so that's beat six
and then on on beat nine you are you are
you are coming all the way down on your ekg
you're spiking downward because they are facing
all their adversity and all of their obstacles
that they must overcome that they
may never they may never recover from
and then if they do recover and they do succeed
and they win in the end then that ekg comes
all the way back up at 12. if they don't if they
don't win then that ekg comes all the way up at 11
and then goes sharply down at 12. so that
is that is basically that 12 point beat
outline now with the 12 point beat outline each
one of those beats 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 has
its own premise so every 10 pages or approximately
10 pages because you don't have to adhere here
strictly to 10 pages because you
know maybe you have a shorter script
has its own log line so you go this is know when
such and such happens such and such occurs cause
and effect it's a cause and effect statement that
is something that is that has a whole chapter
in Author Lajos Egri’s The Art of Dramatic
Writing is the cause and effect statement
that goes all the way back that that can apply all
the way back to the greeks and he takes it there
so so you you you do that for each one of
those beats and then from each one of those
log lines you use those as a basis to to work on
to script those 10 pages or roughly those 10 pages
and then if you adhere to that you'll
you'll you'll probably get yourself a
first draft it may not be much of a first
draft but it'll be something that you can you
can rewrite and that you can work on now that was
my process back in the early days and that's how
I figured things out once once you're writing the
second draft once I was rewriting at that point
that's where I start to apply a little bit of
those tricks a little bit of the fun stuff that's
that's a whole other bit of tools and things
like that there's there's there's refining
that goes in with that sort of thing
you want to look at your script as
what is necessary in the story and what and
tried to take out what is not necessary now
this is one thing that I do believe
many storytellers fail to do
and it doesn't make them bad storytellers it's
just their choice but some some some storytellers
just overload their scenes and they just
want to do so much inside of the scene
and it's not that you don't need to do that to do
a movie to tell to tell a story for the service
of a screenplay that is to be interpreted into a
movie or a film does not require it to be a play
you know if you're going to beat a play you can
make a play you know I write plays myself as well
I think that's fun but it's not required it's
a it's it's something that you you it's a it's
a story that you tell in pictures if I want to
strike another analogy that analogy for me is that
at a certain point for me and this goes towards
the root of the question is that when you get
you you you you figure out your your voice it
becomes a lot like playing music it's like you're
not reading music anymore you you while you play
it you're just kind of improvising a little bit
and you're you're just kind of like going with the
feel you know while you're you know you're jamming
or whatever and the classic example for me is
Thelonious Monk because the thing about Thelonious
Monk that I loved that reminds me of screenwriting
is that he has this syncopation it sounds Ray
Charles too it's very it's also a great one he has
a syncopation that it's not the it's not what he's
playing it's not the court that he's hitting
you know it's what's between it it's the stop
it's in between it that that that is where
you feel the story he's telling in the music
and then the same thing I believe applies
towards towards a good screenplay you know.
Question For The Viewers:
How did you figure out your voice?